alors serge lama comme vous êtes passés
pas loin de la mort lors de votre
accident je vais vous faire une
interview jugement dernier c'est normal
serge lama
a dû voler de l'argent dans le porte
monnaie de ta maman quand tu étais petit
jamais il a volé jamais fait pour piquer
de l'argent à ma mère c'était compliqué
vous savez les titres et provinces et
puis je piquais les sucres serge lama
as-tu copié sur ton voisin en classe
pendant les compos oui
as-tu enfermait des élèves du sexe
féminin dans les cabinets
non
non mais j'avais déjà fait une sale
manie quand j'étais à la maternelle
neuve pas déjà mais je je piquais des
petites filles avec des épingles
et serge lama est ce que tu te reposes
pour ça oui ah oui oui serge lama
as-tu par donner à ta mère oui
serge lama
as tu déjà été tentée par
l'homosexualité
non et j'avais mon meilleur ami qui
était homosexuel et quand comme ça a
marché très mal quand j'étais môme avec
les avec les jeunes filles un jour
j'arrive et puis je dire j'en ai j'en ai
plein monde je vais me taire [ __ ] j'en ai
marre mbia mon pauvre caucourt on peut
pas voir toutes les chansons même temps
serge lama as-tu fait l'amour sans désir
de progrès oui quelle honte
tu te reposes je dirais même que des
fois je les fais volontairement pour ne
pas procréer
serge lama as-tu trompeta femmes
et
c'est ta dernière chance serge lama
ça le jugement dernier
c'est d'entrer au paradis
et avec ma femme c'est entrer au paradis
serge lama as-tu trompeta maîtresse ans
a
fui ma femme comédie serge lama
tu vraiment fréquenter les petites
femmes de pigalle et bah non non moi je
suis plutôt un type à bourgeoise oui je
suis un peu non j'aime oui
serge lama tu préfères les femmes
mariées oui comme ça tu les as pas sur
le dos toute la journée
pas forcément mariés mais aussi oui
d'accord serge lama a tué exiger des
femmes des pratiques contre nature
j'ai pas exigée mais je leur ai demandé
quoi gentiment elles ont dit oui pas
tout
c'était
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu